लुट नमस्कार जर्मन सीखिए हिंदी में के
पहले एपिसोड में आपका स्वागत है मैं केदार
जाधव मैं यूनिक जर्मनी में रहता हूं और
मैं से विकल्प कर इंडस्ट्री में डिजाइन
इंजीनियर हूं पर मेरी असली फैशन है जर्मन
सिखाना जर्मन भाषा का जो सबसे कठिन और
हाईएस्ट लेवल का सर्टिफिकेशन है गए थे
इंस्टीट्यूट का सीटू वह मैंने कंप्लीट
किया है और पिछले चार वर्षो से मैं फ्री
ऑफ कॉस्ट जर्मन सिखा रहा हूं इस दौरान
मैंने 4450 में ग्यारह सौ से ज्यादा
स्टूडेंट्स को जर्मन सिखाई है और उसमें से
अनेक लोगों को वर्थ इंस्टीट्यूट की अनेक
एग्जाम में हंड्रेड परसेंट मार्क्स आइए
अभी यह चैनल शुरू करने के पीछे मेरे दोष
सबसे पहला और सबसे इंपोर्टेंट जिस जिस को
भी मन से जर्मन सीखने की इच्छा है उसे
फ्री ऑफ कर दे
180 खूनी मिलने चाहिए यह मेरा लक्ष्य है
कि आजकल जिसे जर्मन लैंग्वेज अच्छी तरह से
आती है उसके लिए बहुत सारी अपॉर्च्युनिटीज
अवेलेबल है पर दुर्भाग्य से भारत में
जर्मन सीखना इतना आसान नहीं है जो अच्छे
क्लासें उनकी फीस हर लेवल को हजारों रुपये
और टोटल निकायों में उपवास है भी नहीं
दूसरी चीज जब हम जर्मन सीखते हैं अंग्रेज
सिंह ने सीखते हैं और इसी के कारण बहुत
सारी स्टूडेंट्स को कठिनाई होती है और सच
पूछिए तो जरूर और हिंदी में बहुत सारी
समानताएं हैं हिंदी का मेरा मेरी मेरे
जर्मन में है हिंदी का जो आधा बहुवचन है
आप वह जर्मन में है इतना ही नहीं जर्मन और
हिंदी के जो फर्ज है वह एक जैसे ही बिहेव
करते हैं
हैं तो चलिए आज हम हिंदी की मदद से फिर 10
मिनट में कितना सिर्फ 10 मिनट में
छोटे-छोटे जर्मन सेंटेंस बनाना सीखेंगे
चलें करिश्मा
है तो सबसे पहले हम सिर्फ आठ छोटे जर्मन
सर्वनाम सीखेंगे
अच्छा ठीक है सबसे पहले मैं मैं मतलब इस
इस इनको उपचार कैसे करना है हम नेक्स्ट
पार्ट में सीखेंगे अभी आप सिर्फ यह याद
रखिए तो चलेगा मैं मतलब इस तू मतलब तू तू
मतलब तू ही छील इंग्लिश का मतलब हेयर केयर
सिंह मतलब हुई ए मतलब सीईए और एसएमएस
क्रेडिट जो व्यक्ति होता है वह जीवन में
होता है ओके खेल जी थिस
कि जब हम को हम बोलना है हम तब हम बोलेंगे
बियर हुई वीर वो हमको बोलना है तुम दोनों
तुम दोनों तब हम बोलेंगे यह शेयर और जब
हमको
पीलू तेरे खोलना है तो हम फिर से बोलेंगे
जी व्यास बोलोगे हमने तो जिम मतलब सीखा है
तो वह कांटेक्ट बेस्ट होता है मतलब भी
होता है और जी मतलब दे भी होता है जैसे
इंग्लिश में हमने पढ़ा है यू आर किरदार
जगुआर किरदार बोलते हो तो आपको पता यह ही
बंद है पर जब आप बोलती हो युवा स्टूडेंट्स
तो आपको कांटेक्ट से पता चलता है बहुत
सारे है तो एक बार यह एक बचने था और एक
बार यह अनेक बचने था वैसे जैसे-जैसे आप
आगे जाओगे कंडक्टर आपको समझ में है इसे
हिंदी में भी होता है राइट मैं कल आऊंगा
तो समझ लेते हो कि कल लेस ट्यूमर और मैं
कल आया था तो आप समझ सकते हो कि कल यह
स्टर यह दोनों बोधक कल पियर सबको
है तो भी मतलब सीबीआई और भी मतलब देखिए और
अभी मैं आपको और एकदम से दिखाने वाला हूं
कि वह इंग्लिश में नहीं है पर जरूर और
हिंदी में सेम है वह है आ देओल हिंदी में
बोल दे तू और आ इधर से वह जो वह भी जर्मन
में है वह एक कैपिटल जी कैपिटल्स इन आ
तुझे मैं फिर से आपको यह फिर से करता हूं
थोड़े इंग्लिश में से करता हूं तो आपको
आसानी होगी अगर आप यह आपको अभी के अभी को
याद रखने की जरूरत नहीं है यह सिर्फ हमको
आगे लगने वाले हैं इसलिए हम कर रहे हैं
चले का यह इश्क हाय हाउ आर यू
वॉइस मेल जमशेद की पीठ वीर्य युद्ध हुआ था
युद्ध य यु ऑल जी छोटा जी गेंद दें और
कैपिटल मतलब नहीं आ इधर से आपको यह सबसे
इंपोर्टेंट है तो करके थोड़ा शांति से
विचार करो कि इसके सिंपल एकदम सिंपल तो हम
फिर से हिंदी में हिंदी में कैसे सेट करते
हो तो हम थोड़े से कुछ कौन-कौन से हैं
भागना-दौड़ना से अगर यह ना होता तो हम
क्या करते हैं तो
बीमा का हम क्या करते हैं ना कुछ छोड़
देते हैं ना को छोड़ देते हैं और कस्टमर
आते हैं पीली पीली और फिर जब आपको बोलना
है मैं पीता हूं हाइब्रिड तो क्या करता
हूं मैं पीता हूं अपने ताऊ न लगाएं समझे
मैं पीता हूं
कि तुम पीते हो तुम पीते हो वह पीता है यह
ख्याल पिता हूं तुम पीते हो वह पीता है
इसको बोलते हैं व कंजगेशन इसमें मुक्त
इंपोर्टेंट चीज क्या है एक बार अपने
डिसाइड किया कि मैं को आप दांव लगा रहे हो
तो हर बट आई लगाऊंगी अगर खाना है तो मैं
खाना खाता हूं चालू है तो मैं जानता हूं
आना है तो मैं आज तक मैं तोता आएगा इसको
बोलते हैं वर्ग कंडीशन तो कोई डिवाइस करते
क्या किया आपने हर हिंदी वरना से इंडोर
रहा था खाना-पीना आना-जाना हमने ना को
हटाया और मिक्स टीम बनाया है पी और फिर
उसको मैं पीता हूं तुम पीता हूं हम पीते
हैं चलाया अगर आपको बेसिक हिंदी का वर्क
फॉर एजुकेशन क्लियर है तो जर्मन आपको 2
मिनट में आ जाएगा जर्मन में कैसे सेम है
देखते हैं
कि जर्मन में भी हर वर्ग में जो है 990
एडमिट यह कौन उठाना गहन जाना लेहमन सीखना
एडिशन खाना त्रिकोण पीना अगर देखिए
एवरीथिंग एंड मिथक ही काम तो हिंदी कि तरह
करेंगे तो हम यहां पर पीना को पकड़ा था
यहां पर स्क्रीन को पकड़ते हैं आ गया कि
रिंकल अमित रिंगटोन है तो इसका स्टीम क्या
बनेगा हिंदी में नारियों किया यहां के
रिमूव करो कि यह तो उस टाइम बन गया ट्रिंग
ट्रिंग जूनुन हिंदी में पीवण था यहां बन
गए ट्रिक अभी आप क्या करोगे हिंदी में
अपने किया था याद करो मैं कुत्ता हूं
लगाया था मैं पीता हूं यहां पर आ इसको
लगाओगे की
कि अगर आपको बोला है मैं पीता हूं तो आप
बोलोगे इस ट्रिक जो आपका स्लिम है और
लगाऊंगी तो होगा इस ट्रेन के उसका एक छुट
जाता है इस क्रीम को पर अभी के लिए हमको
याद रहे कि हमने की लगाया है हम बोलेंगे
इस प्रेम के कब्जे से मुक्त हिंदी में मैं
है तो ता लगाता हूं वैसे ही जर्मन में
इश्क तो ही लगेगा कभी भी हम आएंगे उस पर
कि अगर दूर है तो वह जर्मनी में कई दिन
आपने क्या किया था तू पीता है यहां पर हम
जूस को लगाएंगे इस टीम
कि तुम पीते हो या फिर क्यों पीता है धूप
त्रिसंध्यं थे रिसेंट
कि अगर ही डिजिट है अगर ही पीठ है तो हम
लगाएंगे टीवीएस
कि वह पीता है एग ट्रिंग ट्रिंग ट्रिंग
क्लियर अगर तुम दोनों पीछे हो बोलना है
तुम दोनों तो बोलेंगे उसको भी TV लगेगा
ईयर का भी होगा कि तो थोड़ा देख विट्टी
निवास करते हैं इस है तो लगाया दूर है तो
लगा है एक्टिव एलर्जी है तो लगा है टिप्स
और क्लियर है तो भी लगाया पीली अब इसके
बाद बहुत पसंद है अगर आपको बोलना है वीर्य
मतलब हम या फिर सी मतलब देगी या कैपिटल जी
आ तीनों केस इसमें हम फिर से लिए नहीं
लगाएंगे मतलब हमने निकाला भी यह डाला भी
तो वीर्य निकल जी रिंकल कैपिटल जीत
रिंकल्स हर कटिंग करनी होगी सिंपल है हम
पीते हैं बेहतर इंसान हैं
कि वे पीते हैं विचित्र अंकल और आप पीते
हो ग्रीन करें तो हर पिक फिर से इक्विटी
निवेश करें तो क्या हुआ इस ट्रेन के
आयोडीन दूसरे यू डिड एवरीथिंग
में ही रिसर्च बेयरिंग इन थे वेडिंग और
विभिन्न कर देगी एकदम सिंपल तो इसे चुर
हमारे मंत्री बन जाता है वह मंत्र आप मेरे
साथ बोलो तो आपको भी आसानी से यह मंत्र या
ना अपने तो हो गया इस क्रीम का दूसरे
का रस बी प्रिंट
कि यह ट्रेन वियर प्रिंस कौन इजी ट्विंकल
सिंपल रेट अब इसको यूज करके तो इतनी जी
लगेगा अभी ने खूब जर्मन इस यौवन कैसे हैं
यूरोपीय लैंग्वेज है तो सारी भारतीय
भाषाएं देखो बहुत सारी है उनमे क्या होता
है वह हमेशा एंड में आता है मैं क्रिकेट
खेलता हूं मी क्रिकेट खेलने तो इसमें
वर्कर है एंड में वैसे ही यूरोपीयन भाषाओं
में सेकंड पोजीशन में होता है जैसे
इंग्लिश में आए प्रिंट तिल
कि आई ड्रिंक कि मैं खुद पेनिस विटामिन भी
सीखता हूं स्पेनिश में होता है योर वेब
पोर्टल योर वोट एक सेकेंड पोजीशन पर व
बकाया वैसे ही जर्मन में भी सेकेंड पोजीशन
फिर और बाकी सब जिसे इंग्लिश में आए
ड्रिंक पीछे मैसेज वन में क्या होगा को
क्या बोलते हैं इस इस और ड्रिंक को क्या
बोलते हैं ड्रिंक करने पर इस है तो
प्रिंटर में से यह टैगर लगेगा क्या की इस
प्रेम कटीली तो हम सब क्या करते हैं कि
पेप्सी भी कह देते हैं कि बच्चे के ऊपर
राहु के व्यक्तित्व हमको जर्मन व सीखने की
जरूरत नहीं है तो वह मैं पेप्सी पीता हूं
इस क्रीम के पेप्सी यूटरिन टिप्सी यह
टेस्टी लगेगा टूट सी सी
जो भी ट्रिक पेप्सी वीडियो त्रिकंद सी
कि वह लोग पेप्सी पीते हैं जी प्रिंट करके
इसी तरह पिज़्ज़ा खा लेते हैं चलो साइड
पिज़्ज़ा और स्पीड साथ या फिर हम क्या
करते हैं अभी क्यों क्रिकेट खेल लेते हैं
ओके क्रिकेट कैसे
कल क्रिकेट खेलना तो बोलते हैं TV हुए
उसका मूल है तो क्या बनेगा पी पी ओ के इस
चतुराई दूर है तो एसटी आई क्लिक पिलर
क्रिकेट यू प्ले क्रिकेट दूसरे पीस करके
रिप्ले क्रिकेट टेस्ट क्रिकेट को हिंदी
सीखने के लिए क्या लहर लहर लहर लहर लहराए
तुम सब कुछ सिंपल हिंदी में इसके बाद जैसे
कि हमने हिंदी में चाहिए पकड़ो उसको उसमें
ना हटाया और मैं तोता हूं तुम हो तो तय हो
झाल सिंपली घी पीना है तो मैं पीतम खराब
है मैं खत्म जर्मन में भी वही प्रदूषणावर
पकड़ो पीएम को रिमूव करो स्टेम बनाओ इस है
तो इस लगाओ दो है तो यह स्टे लगा दिया है
तो यह लगा सिंपल है अभी मैं अभी कैसे हैं
कि हर भाषा में कुछ लोग ऐसे होते हैं या
कुछ चीजें ऐसी होती है जो रूल्स फॉलो नहीं
करती थी जिनको बोलते हैं इन्हें गूलर पर
इसमें भी ऐसे कुछ वायर्स है जो यह मानते
नहीं पर वह जैसे-जैसे हम आगे जाएंगे तब हम
सीखेंगे अभी नए मोर थन नाइनटी पर सेंट आफ
जर्मन वर्ड्स फॉलो थिस रूल तो हम क्या
करेंगे हम यह रेगुलर उग सीखेंगे और अभी भी
जो दिखे उसको हम यह रुख करते जाएंगे
क्लियर है सबको
मैं अभी मैं आपको इतनी देता हूं मैं आपको
इस ट्रिक देता हूं आप सबको स्क्रीन पर
थर्टी वर्ड दिख रहे होंगे यह 30वर्ष यह
आपके डे टुडे लाइफ में लगने वाले सबसे
इंपोर्टेंट थर्टी वर्क है जैसे कॉम आना यह
जानना लेयर न पढ़ना सिंघाना trim विकल्प न
आपको यह से हर रोज खुश
सेंटेंस बनाने कितने पास जो मैंने बोला था
आज तक चार बार यही पढ़ाया चार बार आपको यह
रोटी पापड़ आप हर बार मैं बोलता हूं जो
कोई जो कि ध्यान से जो कोई अरुण सिर्फ
सेंटेंस बनाएगा 3 महीने में 501 लगेगा
मैं अभी इंपोर्टेंट चीज है रोल्स
कंसिस्टेंसी इंपोर्टेंट फिर जैसे-जैसे हम
आगे जाएंगे इस सेंटेंस कंपलेक्स बनाते
जाएंगे पर सिर्फ आप एक नोट बुक लो हर रोज
पांचवें सेंटेंस लिखते जाओ आपका हो गया
अभी कैसे हैं अभी आपका प्रॉब्लम क्या है
थोड़ा मीडियम क्या है कि हम 10 मिनट्स
एजेंसी के फ्लाइट प्रॉब्लम को सिर एस यू
डैडी सर्वनाम आते हैं और गेहूं को मिल
जाता है तो अभी आप क्या करोगे जो वाइट
नहीं आता है वह इंग्लिश में भी कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं आई वांट टू ऑफिस इस गहरा टू
ऑल थिस ई कम फ्रॉम ऑफिस स्पर्म फ्रॉम कोई
व्यक्ति हम के लिए टू फ्रॉम इंग्लिश में
लिखो ने जब अपने टूर फ्रॉम सीख लिया गया
है
यहां पर आप इंपॉर्टेंट क्या है हर रोज 5
सेंटेंस बनाओ और इतने सारे सेंटेंसेस है
कि इसमें बारीक वर्ड लगते भी नहीं मैं
आपको अभी ऐसी इतने सारे सैंडविच बता सकता
हूं कि इसमें डायरेक्ट हंड्रेड परसेंट
करें जर्मन कर सकते हो इस स्पीक्स आफ
हंड्रेड परसेंट करें जर्मन सेंटर सब होता
है इस प्रिंट ए हंड्रेड परसेंट करें यह को
तो आपको क्या करना है जैसे मैंने बोला उस
क्रीम का भी आप अगर आपको चाहिए उसको पॉज
कर लो और वह 30वर्ष आपके नोटबुक में लिख
लो और फिर हर रोज उसके पास सेंटेंस बनाओ
अभी मैं हर वर्ग बोलने में अपनी डीनो
पॉन्टिंग ने टिंडर टाइम उससे अच्छा है कि
हम आगे का सीन सकते हैं इस क्लास
अच्छा ठीक है तो आपको क्या करना है जैसे
मैंने बोला पकड़ो और यह हटवा इसके डू केयर
ऐसी के फांस बना क्लियर है अब जैसे मैंने
बोला कि सिंपल सिंपल सेंटेंसेस बना मैं
थोड़े एग्जांपल्स लेकर बताता हूं आपको कि
जो हंड्रेड परसेंट करें गुर्जर वन सेंटेंस
है सुनो ध्यान से लर्न हिंदी इस लूप हिंदी
दर्पण करें आप लिक्विड स्पिल्ड ओवर
क्रिकेट टीम स्प्रिंट करते क्लियर सबको
वैसे ही हम इसे बना सकते हैं कि जब तक कि
कि वीरवल हिंदी पिछले क्रिकेट बीएसपी लर्न
क्रिकेट जब तक आप नए हो इस और व्यू फ्रॉम
बनो क्योंकि वह इजी है और यह दिमाग के लिए
इजी है जैसे-जैसे वृद्ध दो तीन चार दिन ऐश
और बीयर के पास सेंटेंस बनाते जाओ
जैसे-जैसे आगे जाओगे दो एड्रेस जी के
बनाते जाओगे उसी टाइम आप नेक्स्ट कंसेप्ट
सीखते जाओगे तो आपके लिए वह आसान होता
जाएगा तो अभी सबको क्लियर है एवरीबॉडी नोज
हाउ टू मेक स्माल जब इन सेंटेंसेस देखो
हमने सिर्फ 10 मिनट में स्मॉल स्मॉल जर्मन
सेंटेंस बनाना सीखा है
अब तो आ गया सबको कॉन्फिडेंस किया
छोटे-छोटे जर्मन सेंटेंस बना सकते हो हर
कोई 5 सेंटेंस जर्मन में हर रोज बनाएगा का
यह सिंपल है ना ऐसे ही हम हर बाहर जर्मन
में नए कंसेप्ट हिंदी कंटेंट का सहारा
लेते हुए सीखते जाएंगे ऑलरेड मेरे नो
वीडियोस अपलोड किए हैं आएगा प्रोडक्ट नाइन
वीडियो उसके लिंक आपको डिस्क्रिप्शन में
इस वीडियो के मिल जाएगी वैसे ही मैं हर
हफ्ते नए-नए वीडियो अपलोड करते जाऊंगा तो
इसीलिए यह मेरे आप सबसे रिक्वेस्ट है कि
आप मेरे इस चैनल को सब्सक्राइब कीजिए लाइक
कीजिए और आपके जो कोई दोस्त यह सीखना
चाहते हैं जर्मन कि उनके साथ भी शेयर
कीजिए और आपके कुछ भी डाउट हो अगर आपको
इसमें कुछ भी प्रॉब्लम हो आप कमेंट सेक्शन
में लिखिए मैं वह डोंट सॉल्व करने की पूरी
कोशिश करूंगा
हैं नेक्स्ट पार्ट में हम सीखेंगे जरूर फल
पावै तो मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट पार्ट में
जर्मन सीखिए हिंदी में धन्यवाद